[BLING SOUND]
And so I'm really
excited to be here today
to have this opportunity
to talk with you
and be invited to give a talk.
And so first, I
want to say, I get
to be the one here
to give a talk.
But what I'm going
to talk about today
is the contributions
of many people
that make all of
this work possible
and drive the energy
and enthusiasm
of this project and so
much of what we talk about.
I mean, so just in
this room contributing
to what I'm going
to talk about today,
we have [INAUDIBLE]
and Jenny and two
of our staff here, Kerry
Jordan and Francois Michonneau.
We have Greg Wilson, the
founder of Software Carpentry,
Jason Williams, who served
on the executive council
of Software Carpentry,
Kate Hertweck who
is on the current
executive council, Arthur
Graham on the Data
Carpentry executive council.
So this is really
a community effort.
And so I want to attribute that
and represent that in this talk
because it's a part of
that inclusive approach
that we're trying to take.
So I think we've seen throughout
this meeting something that's
really important is that we now
have data and tools to advance
progress and address questions
in science and society.
There's so much potential
in what everybody's
been talking about in the last
couple of days with the data.
And then just, I
mean, the revolution
in the tools available
in the R ecosystem
has been amazing over
the last couple of years.
We're in a place
where we weren't even
a couple of years ago.
And we still talk a
little bit, though,
about the compute and the data.
How do we bring compute to
data or data to compute?
But we need to talk about
how we scale our impact,
talking about bringing
people to data.
So you're in this room.
You could be at any other talk.
You could be doing anything
else with your life.
Why is this the most important
thing to be talking about?
Why is teaching people
how to work with data--
we have a lot of
social challenges--
why is this one
the most important?
And so I want to
point to this quote
from Yeshimabeit Milner,
who is the founder of Data
for Black Lives.
And that "data becomes a tool
of profound social change
or a weapon of political
warfare depending
on whose hands it is in."
So we need to think
about as we have
this data that
this data is power
and that we need to democratize
these skills to give people
the power of thinking
about where they're headed,
of how to interpret
data, how to use
data to answer the questions
that are important for them.
So this to me is one of the
most important questions
that we're facing right now as
we look ahead to where we're
going and seeing a data-driven
world ahead of us, in fact,
that we're in already.
So then if this is the most
important question, getting
more people to be able
to work with data,
how do we scale the number
of people who can do this?
So that's what we're trying to
think about in the Carpentry.
So The Carpentries is a
nonprofit organization.
And we're an open, global
community teaching researchers
the skills to turn
data into knowledge.
And we do this
through curriculum,
open collaborative curriculum,
instructor training, teaching
people how to teach,
and community,
by building and
fostering a community
around these practices and
about sharing knowledge.
So I'm going to try an
analog survey approach here.
We'll see how it goes.
So in reflecting on your
own learning experiences,
who in this room
has been-- and I'm
going to tell you a way to
answer this question-- who
in this room has been in
a course or a workshop
where they felt like
they didn't belong?
So if you say, yes, to that,
we're going to clap twice.
OK?
[CLAP, CLAP]
OK.
So that's a couple of people.
Good analog survey approach.
OK.
So how many people, after
having that experience,
left that topic for a while?
[CLAP, CLAP]
So we have no idea how
many people that is.
But at least, it's a few, right?
So feeling like you
belong in that course
is really important for how you
continue to learn that topic.
So in The Carpentries,
I'll talk about how many
workshops we've taught.
But it's been a lot.
And so something
that we realized
when we were trying
to measure our impact
or think about
what was important
is that we realized it's not
about a specific skill set.
It's not about, can you
parse this line of code?
Can you construct a
function in this way?
But that it's about establishing
a growth mindset around data
and code and people
feeling like they belong,
that data science is for them.
And so the growth mindset is a
bit of a loaded term right now.
And does it work,
does it not work?
So I'm not going
to talk about that.
But what I do want to say
is, what does it mean to us
right now when we say that?
So it means confidence.
The confidence that
this is something
you can do or continue doing.
That we focus on effort
and incremental learning
and not outcomes.
That you don't need
to immediately get
something right.
And seeing mistakes as
opportunities for learning
and having an opportunity
for a safe space
to make those mistakes
to continue learning.
So we want to work towards
this growth mindset using
inclusive pedagogy.
So not focusing-- we do
focus on what we teach.
That is a big thing.
I'm not talking
about that right now.
But how we teach.
And so that's what I
want to talk about now.
And so we're thinking
about it in the context--
and for the people that are
in there, and they're saying,
I've never actually
heard us say it this way.
That is true.
So we're thinking about
taking all of the things
that we do every day and
stepping back and saying, what
is it that this represents is
these four A's, Accessible,
Approachable,
Aligned, and Active.
So what are these things mean
in the context of a learning
environment?
Accessible, so available
in a time and a place
where people can attend.
So that's really important
because if you have things
on weekends and you can't
have child care on weekends,
you can't go on weekends.
But maybe you can't get away
from work during the week.
Or maybe only can do evenings.
Maybe you only can
do online because you
can't leave your house.
There are a lot of different
ways that we can deliver things
so that it's accessible
to people in a time
and a place that works for them.
That it's welcoming so
that when they are there
that it is accessible to them
because of the environment
that's created.
So in all of our workshops,
we have a code of conduct.
And we have a
reporting structure.
Those are both important, not
just having a code of conduct.
And we start with that.
I appreciate in this
meeting that they
started with a code of conduct
because it sets the stage
as saying that this
is a place that
is supposed to be accessible
and welcoming to everybody.
And being proactive about
ensuring accessibility needs.
So I think we still have
work to do in this front.
But looking at your
website resources,
looking at your color schemes.
A lot of great R
packages around that.
Looking through the lens of
accessibility for everybody,
not just for the largest
percentage of learners.
Approachable.
So this is accessible.
I can go to this thing.
But do I want to go?
Is this for me?
And so that starts
at the very beginning
and advertising and
recruitment for the workshop.
If this is for
beginners, say, this
is for people with little
to no prior experience
in this domain, map
out, essentially,
what your persona is of this
person who can come and tell
these people who it's for
and why they're welcome.
Invite them to participate.
Meeting learners where they are.
So understanding that someone
might be working in Excel
and that they maybe
primarily only
had experience with their
computers for Netflix.
That's not a bad thing.
That's where people are.
Let's appreciate where people
are and meet them there
rather than hoping that
they're someplace else.
And that is what helps
make it approachable.
We're creating that
on-ramp for them.
And we're putting the
on-ramp in front of them
instead of like way
the heck over there
or a humongous step in
front of them to start.
And that helps overcome
activation barriers
to getting started.
And then, of course, the
mistakes are the pedagogy.
So in our workshops,
so we'll talk
about how we use like a
participatory live coding
approach.
So you always make mistakes
when you're doing it in person.
But we treat that as a part
of the learning opportunity.
Seeing other people,
when they make mistakes,
when they don't know
what's going on,
helps you understand, one, how
you approach fixing a mistake,
and also that that's OK.
And I think since we're
supposed to quote Hadley, that's
something that
Hadley always says is
that he has to Google things.
It's not that everyone knows
everything and never makes
mistakes.
Aligned.
They're all sort of similar.
But the aligned is really
about the motivation.
So teaching with data sets
that are relevant to the user.
So we had a great discussion
this morning at the Data
For Good [INAUDIBLE]
about using data
sets that the students
were really excited about.
And that got them
excited about the topic.
Because if you're trying
to introduce some topic
that they're not excited
about and teach a skill on top
of that, you're trying to do
two things at the same time.
So starting with a topic that
people are excited about.
Teaching the skills
and perspectives
relevant to their current work.
So, yeah.
You might hold down the road
think that everybody should
know C++.
But if that person is
not going to use it
right away in
their context, then
it's not going to be
something that sticks,
that understands-- they
understand why it's important
and will motivate them
to keep using the tool.
Instructors that are current in
the field, so peer instruction.
So some of our best
instructors are
people who were learners only
a year ago because, one, they
understand the misconceptions.
They're very familiar with
what that process looks like.
So when they see that
something doesn't-- one
doesn't understand something,
then they can relate to that,
help guide someone
through that process.
They also are peers.
They're an ecologist or a social
scientist or an economist.
And so they can put the
things into context.
And so it helps in guiding
their learning as well.
And teaching the current
tools, so looking around.
What is it that
people are using?
Teach what you're
using in your work.
And again, that's going to
be something that helps them
continue with their learning.
And finally, active.
And this is one of the ones that
we really like to talk about.
And this is a little bit
that idea of guided practice,
that you can get
feedback on what you're
doing as you're learning.
That's one of the challenges
of learning on your own
is that you often can't get
that feedback right away.
And so participatory
live coding,
that's the instructor
at the front
of the room going through code
and having the learners go
through it at the same time.
So you're participating
together in doing that coding.
An I-We-You model for teaching.
So I describe something.
We do it together.
You do it yourself.
It gives you a chance to
try it out on your own
but not completely
without a safety net.
All of our curriculum is
open-source and collaboratively
developed and
updated to represent
the current practices.
So our curriculum is active,
actually, in and of itself.
Oh, I see.
[INAUDIBLE],, in fact,
introduced Tidyverse
to our Data Carpentry lessons.
So we have people who
are in the field that
are active and
engaged in the topics
so that they kind of meet
those first three As.
We have helpers
in our workshops.
So not only the instructor
at the front of the room
but someone who goes
around and talks
with people to create a
strong 5 to 1 student ratio.
And then, finally,
our most famous
probably is formative assessment
through using sticky notes.
So you completed an exercise.
You put a green sticky
note on your laptop.
And if you're having trouble,
you put a pink sticky note.
And someone will come help you.
So it's a way
during the workshop,
not just waiting till the
end and saying, oh, my gosh.
If people get it, here's a
survey of seeing as you go,
getting a sense of the
room, assigning help
when it's needed.
So it's a form of
formative assessment,
assessing as you're going
during the workshop.
So there was a bunch--
like our whole concepts
of instructor classroom training
that is two days, smushed
into about five minutes.
So you saw some of the
instructor training
earlier this week
if you were there.
But all of our instructor
training curriculum
is also online.
Like all of our lessons,
it's all [INAUDIBLE]..
So the question is, if
what we're aiming for
is confidence and continued
learning, how are we doing?
How does this approach
work in terms of meeting
those identified goals?
So first, how many
workshops have we taught?
So since 2012, we have
over 1,600 instructors,
over 39,000 learners, and we've
taught over 1,700 workshops.
So not only have we
taught a lot of them,
we've had a global reach.
So this is a map of the
workshops over time,
getting brighter in color
as we have more workshops.
And Francois did
this great plot.
And I'm super-excited
about it so [LAUGHS]..
And you can see we got
Antarctica in last year.
So, very excited about that.
One person taught that.
We think we should just
put her name on Antarctica.
She just claims the whole thing.
So we've also been
able to have--
because of this volunteer
approach, approaching teaching
from the perspective of
meeting learners where they are
and scaling impact,
we've been able to reach
a lot of different communities.
OK.
So the first one we're trying
to achieve is confidence.
So how did we do?
So this is a survey of students.
This is just Data Carpentry.
It's not all R. Most of
Data Carpentries are R.
But some are Python as well.
So pre and post,
two days, how much
has people's perception of their
abilities and their confidence
changed?
So the first question is, I'm
able to write a program that
would solve a small problem.
So we see these full point
differences around programs.
I'm able to search for answers.
I'm able to make my
programming more reproducible,
overcome a problem, become
more efficient in programming.
I know to keep my raw data raw.
I'm very invested
in that question.
And then that last
one, confidence
in programming, so I have
confidence in my ability
to program.
That was one of
our lowest scores
right before the workshop.
And it's increasing a
full point in two days.
I mean, you might say
maybe that confidence
is misplaced after two days.
But the point is is that
they feel like it's for them.
People feel like it's for them.
And so these are some
of the words that people
use to describe
the workshop that
reflects those ideals that
we have around inclusivity
and accessibility.
And you always see
instructors and helpful.
And so it represents
a lot of those things
that I've talked about
with our practices.
Not only are people more
confident after two days,
but when we survey people
more than six months
after a workshop-- and this
does have a bias because only
certain people answer
surveys that you send out
way along later.
What is the percentage?
Basically 100-- almost 100%
of people more than six months
after a workshop say that
they are more confident.
I don't know.
You don't look surprised.
I'm surprised [LAUGHS].
I do programming.
I don't always
feel more confident
after I've spent a day
programming, I can tell you.
So I mean, this to
me that is not only
this sort of short-term
effect of two days
but that long-term, this feeling
persists is very important.
Continued learning.
Do people go on to
continue learning?
So this is, again, that
longer term survey.
Have you gone on to continue
learning after the workshop?
So most people agree or
strongly agree that they've
gone on to continue learning.
And these are using these
skills in their work,
improving overall
efficiency, managing data.
So people are regularly
using these practices.
Again, when they
come back to reflect
on what this has meant to them,
what they're capable of now,
these are some of the
words that they use.
And they strongly recommend
their workshops to others.
So almost 80% have recommended
the workshop to someone else.
Our Net Promoter score--
if you're into Net Promoter
scores-- is like over 9.
Is that the right thing?
The number of people that
want to recommend these
to other people
also reflects on how
they felt about that
experience, not just
about what they
thought they learned.
So safe spaces for
continued learning,
that was that last one
around a [INAUDIBLE]
mindset because we want
people to continue learning.
How do they do that?
So one way that they're seeing
that, people will continue
to engage with our
community, sometimes
going on to become
instructors or helpers.
But they do a lot
of other things.
Sometimes they use
Carpentry lessons.
They use short courses.
They go to meetups.
They go to
semester-long courses.
So when we talk about
this after the workshop,
we know some of that.
But what they're really
doing is they're diving
into a community of practice.
And so seeing these practices
that exist is really important.
And so we're lucky here with
our ladies and all the things
that people talked
about that they
do have welcoming
communities of practice
to continue to learn in.
So see that there's
some elements that
make this important.
And so then the
question is, so great.
Awesome.
People like it.
But I said at the beginning
that one of our goals
is reaching diverse communities.
And how are we doing?
Well, gender, I guess would
say pretty rep-- this is just
in the United States
because that's
the only place we collect
demographic data because
of legal reasons.
We're not doing so well.
So we need to do better.
So there are elements of
creating a space where
people feel welcome.
There's more
opportunities for that.
There's more opportunities
for recruitment.
And so what we want to say here
is that with this ecosystem,
with this community of practice
that people are building,
with all of these different
teaching practices,
that we together
are an ecosystem.
And that if we want to
go fast, we can go alone.
And then if we want to
go far, we go together.
And there's great
opportunities for that here.
And we look forward
to continuing
to work with all of
these communities
and building our future
together around data.
Thank you.
[BLING SOUND]